cette vidéo est destinée en priorité aux
élèves de prépa hec
mais si ça n'est pas votre cas ne passez
pas votre chemin pour autant car vous
pouvez vous aussi y trouver un véritable
intérêt cette vidéo peut vous apporter
quelque chose à vous aussi si vous
cherchez à améliorer la qualité de votre
rédaction et à développer votre capacité
à synthétiser l'information ce que je
vais faire c'est commenter dans le
détail une copie de contraction c'est à
dire un résumé de texte qui a été notée
20 au concours d'entrée à hec de 2017
alors le candidat a été admis à jour
vous pouvez télécharger le sujet est la
copie du candidat en cliquant sur le
lien dans la description et vous pouvez
regarder la vidéo sans prendre de notes
parce que je vous donne également mais
note de commentaire
avec le sujet la copie comme ça vous
êtes tranquille enfin posez moi toutes
vos questions dans les commentaires et
je m'engage à répondre à chacune d'entre
elles alors maintenant petite
explication pour les non-initiés
l'épreuve dite de contraction consiste à
résumer un texte assez ardu de cinq six
pages en 400 mots plus ou moins 5%
c'est à dire plus ou moins 20 morts à
l'énoncé de l'épreuve s'était plus
précisément résumé en 400 mots plus ou
moins 5% soit 384 120 mo le texte
suivant en vous attachant à mettre en
valeur les idées essentielles et les
articulations de la pensée de l'auteur
et puis en dessous il est aussi demandé
de comptes et les mots de rester un
personnel décrire clairement et bien sûr
la calculette et l'iphone sont interdits
voilà voilà
si vous voulez en savoir plus sur les
conventions de l'exercice google est
votre ami
alors encore une fois téléchargé le
sujet la copie de l'élève et même mes
notes de commentaires en cliquant sur le
lien dans la description parce que vous
allez en avoir besoin pour me suivre
bon pour autant je ne vais pas non plus
vous demander de lire le texte en entier
même si vous pouvez le faire je vais
vous le présenter rapidement et puis je
ferai surtout des remarques
forme sans revenir dans le détail du
texte initial je le signalais quand même
si des idées essentielles manque ou si
des idées retenues ne sont pas
essentiels mais ça ne constituera pas le
coeur de mon commentaire
mon objectif c'est surtout d'évaluer
l'efficacité du texte final est tout à
la fin de la vidéo
je dirais si je suis d'accord avec le
correcteur puis je répondrai à la
question comment avoir 20 ans
contractions alors le texte du sujet
maintenant c'est un extrait d'un essai
du philosophe assez connu françois
jullien et dans cet extrait il compare
les stratégies militaires et les
stratégies du discours à partir de la
pensée chinoise mais aussi de la pensée
occidentale
je le résume très rapidement il explique
tout d'abord les caractéristiques et les
concepts profond de la stratégie
militaire chinoise il montre ensuite que
la stratégie grecque repose elle sur des
principes inverse qui s'explique en
partie par la conception du discours
dans la cité grecque
enfin il étend cette intuition la racine
rhétorique de la stratégie militaire à
la civilisation chinoise
encore une fois n'oubliez pas de
télécharger le sujet est la copie en
cliquant sur le lien dans la description
si vous voulez vraiment me suivre allez
c'est parti je me mets dans les habits
du correcteur on commence par voir la
première impression qui a probablement
produite la copie alors l'écriture est
plutôt propre
ça n'est pas de la grande calligraphie
mais honnêtement c'est très lisible on
peut peut-être regretter que ça ne soit
pas plus aéré le candidat aurait pu
sauter quelques lignes tout au début et
puis aussi espacer les paragraphes le
décompte des mots est bien présent
les slash dans le texte tous les 50 mo
et puis le nombre dans la marge
je passe
la page suivante je descends les
paragraphes fonte à peu près la même
taille à vue d'oeil
une quinzaine de lignes donc l'équilibré
global du texte semble bon on arrive au
décompte final
413 mots c'est nickel tu le sais
peut-être il est recommandé d'écrire au
moins 4 110 mo sinon le correcteur se
dira qu'il manque probablement une ou
plusieurs idées essentielles donc 413
c'est parfait alors mini conclusions sur
la première impression c'est globalement
positif parce que les consignes sont
respectées le nombre de mots est bon et
puis c'est bien lisible il aurait pu à
errer un peu mais bon ce n'est pas très
grave je chipote un peu mais ça n'est
pas parce qu'elle a été notée vin qu'il
ne faut pas critiquer la copie elle ne
fait pas forcément non plus un bon
modèle bien sûr la première impression
ne permet pas de deviner que la copie
mérite une note excellente
la seule chose qu'on sache à ce stade
c'est que c'est un travail a priori ces
règles pour en savoir plus il faut lire
la copie dans le détail
je vais donc là commenté paragraphe par
paragraphe
c'est parti première phrase les
stratèges chinois dont l' influence
s'étend au reste de la pensée chinoise
ont insisté sur un principe majeur
éviter la bataille frontale
il commence son paragraphe part évoqué
la caractéristique principale de la
stratégie chinoise
c'est bien sûr le fond puisque c'est
évidemment une idée essentielle du texte
source qui fera des caractéristiques de
la stratégie chinoise
et puis c'est bien aussi sur la forme
parce que pour qu'un paragraphe soit
très clair il faut que la première
phrase en exposé l'idée principale
et puis les suivantes la développe la
phrase en est même est très claire les
mots ne sont pas compliquées ma seule
mini réticences c'est que ça aurait pu
être encore plus direct la proposition
dont l' influence s'étend au reste de la
pensée chinoise n'est pas super utile et
elle coupe le rythme de la phrase moi
j'aurais écrit plus simplement les
stratèges chinois ont fondé leur théorie
sur un principe majeur éviter la
bataille frontale
de manière générale c'est mieux de se
limiter à un seul verbe conjugué dans la
première phrase d'un paragraphe mais
sinon la phrase est efficace donc je
passe à la suivante
il faut au contraire savoir anticiper
l'adversaire pour bloquer sa stratégie
et ainsi vaincre sans avoir à combattre
alors sur le fond il précise l'idée de
la phrase précédente
donc c'est cohérent le lien est bien
mise en évidence c'est un lien logique
d'opposition avec l'allocution au
contraire sur la forme c'est plutôt
efficace
on comprend bien mais il y a quelques
petites imprécisions lexical c'est
plutôt la stratégie adverse et non pas
l'adversaire qui doit être anticipée et
puis bloqué la stratégie n'est pas
terrible j'aurais plutôt écrit quelque
chose comme entraver ces manoeuvres
mais bon encore une fois cet efficace
parce qu on comprend facilement
donc je continue le bon général maîtrise
alors aussi bien l'affrontement direct
qu'indirects d'abord dans l'aspect
purement militaire mais également dans
la stratégie qu'il s'est dissimulé pour
surprendre son adversaire
cette phrase précise la précédente elle
dit comment se traduit le principe
stratégique à l'échelle du général
l'adverbe alors montre bien qu'il s'agit
sur le plan logique d'une conséquence
pour autant jeu
ne trouve pas la phrase super clair
c'est surtout la distinction de l'aspect
purement militaire et de l'aspect
stratégique que je ne trouve pas clair
sur le fond même si elle est faite
clairement sur la forme
et puis je trouve que la proposition
relative qu'il s'est dissimulé pour
surprendre son adversaire est hors sujet
par rapport à l'idée générale de la
phrase le candidat aurait dû se limiter
à l'idée de la maîtrise des deux types
d'afrique
il aurait par exemple pu l'écrire le bon
général maîtrise alors aussi bien
l'affrontement direct ou indirect au
niveau de la préparation comme de la
mise en pratique là à parler de
préparation ça permet d'éviter la
redondance du terme stratégie qui risque
d'être pas mal à répéter dans la
contraction en tout cas première phrase
pas génial clairement moins efficace que
les précédentes
je continue cette logique tire son
fondement du fait que le rapport direct
lorsqu'une chose en cause une autre est
plus faible que le rapport indirect ou
la chose simplement en puissance
en cause une autre parce que n'étant pas
réaliser la chose impossible à bloquer
bon je me suis levé en forme ce matin
mais là je commence à avoir mal à la
tête mais qu'est ce qu'il est allé faire
dans cette galère
la phrase est bien évidemment trop
compliqué et puis sur la forme
l'expression tire son fondement du fait
que n'est pas génial le nom commun chose
et le verbe causés sont répétés et on
retrouve le verbe bloqués il était déjà
dans les paragraphes précédents verbe
qui en plus n'est pas super moi j'aurais
plutôt écrire quelque chose comme la
supériorité fondamentale d'une stratégie
indirecte repose sur l'impossibilité
d'empêcher la menace ou la dissuasion
qui ne sont pas des actions effectives
bon comme la france n'est pas assez
clair j'en ai oublié ses qualités elle
est quand même bien liée à la précédente
par l'adjectif démonstratif 7
et elle l'a développe en en expliquant
le fondement théorique mais elle
explique mal bon c'est dommage le
paragraphe ne se termine pas très bien
petite conclusion pour ce premier
paragraphe il est globalement efficace
il expose bien les idées essentielles du
texte source
il est bien cohérent avec la première
phase qui expose général et le reste du
paragraphe qui la développe c'est fluide
chaque phrase est liée à la précédente
et il ya quasiment un lien logique par
phrase enfin il n'y a pas de faux
docteur s'est globalement clair mais la
dernière phrase fait un peu tache
et j'ai souligné quelques petits défauts
ci ou là on voit donc déjà que cette
copie n'est pas parfaite alors même
qu'elle a été notée 20 je passe au
paragraphe suivant première phrase je
voudrais je voudrais interrogées cette
conception en la comparant à celle des
grecs qui s'affrontaient en bataille
frontale alors ce qui saute aux yeux
c'est qu'il se permet de recourir à la
première personne du singulier
je le dis sans détour il ne faut pas
faire ça je rappelle que l'énoncé
stipule que l'exercice doit rester un
personnel dans le fond comme dans la
forme
j'ai lu une vingtaine de contraction
noter entre 17 et 20 ont concours
d'entrée à hec en 2017
et c'est bien la seule où le candidat se
permet de faire ça donc encore une fois
c'est à éviter même si le correcteur a
été tolérant il a probablement été
tolérant parce que la phrase est à la
fois très pertinente
elle délivre exactement la deuxième
grande idée de textes sources et elle
est aussi ultra clair elle oppose très
simplement la conception chinoise à la
conception occidentale dans bon avec
cette efficacité de style
il peut y avoir un effet de compensation
on jugera par la suite
je continue v en somme v hanson a
expliqué que ce rapport frontal était la
conséquence d'un choix délibéré
une bataille rapide ou le résultat est
clair il y a encore quelque chose qui
saute aux yeux il cite un auteur ça
n'est pas rédhibitoire parce qu'il ne
s'agit pas de moteur du texte source
mais il est fortement recommandé de ne
pas le faire la consigne de base c'est
de ne sélectionner une information qu à
la condition qu'elle ait la force d'un
argument est qu'elle soit essentielle
dans le texte source
c'est bien qu'il faut rendre à césar ce
qui est à césar mais là c'est inutile de
mentionner l'auteur de la thèse sur le
fond c'est toujours pareil
elle précise la phrase précédente elle
en donne la cause donc c'est bien
cohérent sur la forme
elles sont liées l'une à l'autre par
l'allocution ce rapport frontal
sinon la phrase est très clair avec un
vocabulaire très simple moi j'aurais
plutôt écrit ce rapport frontal est la
conséquence d'une préférence pour une
bataille à rapide aux résultats
incontestables
je passe à la phrase suivante toute
stratégie pour perturber l'adversaire
été rejetée pas parce que les grecs
ignorait la stratégie de l'affrontement
direct mais parce qu'ils ne se sont pas
concentrés dessus là il n'y a pas de
lien explicite avec la phrase précédente
maison comprend bien qu'elle en
développe l'idée elle dit que les grecs
se sont focalisés sur les stratégies
direct donc c'est bien cohérent sur la
forme et j'ai quand même plusieurs
réticences j'aurais plutôt parler de
stratégie de perturbation de
l'adversaire il faut écrire non pas
parce que ils n'ont pas pas parce que
qui relève d'un style plutôt orale le
most raté
j ai répété dans la phrase il faut une
virgule avant eux mais pour indiquer la
pose de lecture enfin si le verbe
ignorer est un parfait alors le verbe
concentré doit l'être aussi parce que
les deux actions sont sur le même plan
on pourrait écrire parce qu'il l'a
délaissée volontairement donc bonne
phrase sur le fond mais elle peut être
améliorée sur la forme je continue les
travaux de monsieur détiennent les
travaux de monsieur détiennent
conduisent même à penser que c'est une
conception générale des grecs qui lient
leurs principes militaires à leur
système politique
bon je rappelle qu'il ne faut pas faire
de référence je ne reviens pas sur cette
consigne
le lien avec la phrase précédente est
évident c'est un lien logique d'addition
signalé par l'adverbe même pour autant
l'idée plutôt mal exprimé l' idée
précise du texte source
c'est que la préférence des grecs pour
les stratégies direct des coupes d'une
conception plus générale une conception
qu'on retrouve aussi dans le système
politique grecque
je vous renvoie au sujet de l'épreuve
que vous pouvez télécharger en cliquant
sur le lien dans la description si vous
voulez clarifier ça sur la forme
maintenant c'est plutôt efficace
la nuance du texte source le fait qu'il
s'agisse d'une hypothèse est bien
retranscrite avec l'allocution conduire
à penser
et puis les mots sont simples et bien
choisi phrase suivante
retrouve-t-on aussi ce choix de
l'affrontement direct au sein du débat
dans la cité ce qui saute aux yeux c'est
qu'il s'agit d'une question
alors moi je déconseille les questions
en contraction
parce que c'est compliqué à faire mais
bon ça a des avantages ça permet
notamment de fluidifier le texte de le
redynamiser
ici la question revient à interroger
dans le détail
l'hypothèse exposés par la phrase
précédente c'est comme si on demandait
est ce que c'est bien vérifier sur la
forme c'est parfaitement clair rien à
dire donc je continue
le débat se construit par un échange
d'arguments évalué par l'auditoire qui
finalement vote
cette phrase déclaratives répond tout
simplement à la question l'idée
l'affrontement direct par les arguments
et juste
rien à dire sur le fond sur la forme la
phrase est très clair mais pas très
élégante notamment la proposition
relative qui finalement vote
j'aurais plutôt écrit le débat consiste
en un échange d'arguments qui forgent
l'opinion politique et donc le vote de
l'audience mais bon la phrase est quand
même relativement efficace je passe à la
suivante
il s'agit comme lors des batailles de
déterminer rapidement et clairement le
vainqueur avec l'allocution il s'agit de
elle précise clairement la phrase
précédente en donnant la finalité
implicite du débat dans la cité grecque
donc c'est cohérent sur la forme elle
est extrêmement clair on peut remarquer
que lui deux dernières phrases sont très
claires notamment parce qu'elles sont
courtes en effet plus une phrase est
longue plus le risque qu'elles ne soient
pas suffisamment claire est important
je continue c'est sans doute une des
causes qui expliquent pourquoi la chine
n'a pas cette tradition du vote
équivalent à un affrontement direct le
lien avec la phrase précédente est
clairement établi avec l'allocution
c'est là le candidat évoque une
conséquence de la finalité implicite du
vote comme le processus du vote est une
manière directe de désigner un vainqueur
il ne s'est pas imposé dans la tradition
chinoise sur la forme c'est bien clair
pas très élégant la construction double
proposition subordonnées avec qui
explique et pourquoi mai
super j'aurais plutôt écrit quelque
chose comme cette finalité implicite est
probablement une des causes de l'absence
du vote dans la tradition chinoise
mais bon je reconnais que j'aime bien
chipoter la phrase est quand même très
clair je continue
cela montre également tout le caractère
culturel du vote liens logiques
d'addition avec l'adverbe également
c'est très bien sur le fond il s'agit d'
une induction par rapport à l'année
précédente
parce que le candidat tire une idée
générale d'une idée précise de l'absence
du vote dans la tradition chinoise ce
qui est factuel il induit le caractère
culturel du vote
bref c'est un peu précis tout ça mais ça
prouve bien la cohérence de la phrase
par rapport à la précédente et par
rapport au paragraphe sur la forme
la phrase est encore plus courte que les
précédentes et donc conformément aux
probabilités très clair conclusion pour
ce deuxième paragraphe on retrouve les
qualités du premier
les idées sont bien sélectionner c'est
très clair c'est très cohérent et puis
très fluide mais il ya quand même
quelques imprécisions de faux et puis
des défauts de forme et puis surtout il
ya une véritable prise de risque le
candidat a écrit à la première personne
du singulier
ici des auteurs et il pose une question
ça fait quand même beaucoup
je trouve mais bon le correcteur a
probablement estimé que c'était
largement compensé par la grande clarté
du paragraphe notamment à la fin où les
phrases sont plus courtes et plus direct
voyons voir si le candidat continue sur
sa lancée avec le paragraphe suivant
première phrase il me semble
il me semble que cette opposition est
également présente dans les conceptions
logique des deux cultures
bon le candidat se permet encore de ne
pas respecter la consigne d'un
personnalités donné par l'énoncé
d'ailleurs salle autorise à utiliser
l'indicatif sans le pronom personnel
mais il faudrait écrire soit également
présente
mais bon c'est juste un petit détail
le mieux c'est de rester totalement
impersonnel
sur le fond on retrouve bien l'idée
essentielle du texte source selon
laquelle l'opposition entre les
stratégies directs et indirects exprime
une différence culturelle fondamentale
pour autant cette idée générale n'est
pas exprimé très clairement il faut
préciser qu'il s'agit de l'opposition
entre les deux types de stratégie et
puis conception logique est beaucoup
trop précis la logique c'est précisément
le processus qui permet de passer
rigoureusement d'une idée à une autre il
fallait plutôt parler de paradigme
intellectuelle c'est un détail mais
l'adverbe également et répété or il
n'est pas nécessaire d'utiliser un
connecteur logique dans la première
phrase d'un paragraphe au total moi
j'aurais plutôt écrit quelque chose
comme l'opposition entre les stratégies
grecque et chinoises reflète la profonde
différence entre deux paradigmes
intellectuel culturel phrase suivante
lors d'un débat grec
deux idées s'oppose par des arguments
assimilables à des unités mathématiques
aisément quantifiables
là il développe l'idée précédente en
évoquant d'abord la conception
culturelle grec telle qu'elle s'exprime
dans le débat donc c'est quand
sur la forme je trouve que c'est parfait
c'est précis c'est très clair et les
mots sont justes
rien à dire donc je passe à la phrase
suivante
le vainqueur est celui qui en un cumul
le plus comme le nombre d'hommes
entraîne la victoire lors du combat
cette phrase précise la fin de la
précédente avec le prenons en qui
renvoie aux unités mathématiques
aisément quantifiables
donc c'est évidemment cohérent alors on
comprend très bien la comparaison entre
l'accumulation des arguments dans un
débat et l'accumulation des soldats dans
une bataille mais ça n'est pas dit très
élégamment moi j'aurais plutôt écrit le
vainqueur est celui qui en accumule le
plus de la même manière que la taille
des troupes est un facteur décisif de la
victoire militaire
je continue en chine le débat est
également conçu en tant qu affrontements
petite remarque préliminaire
il faut une virgule après en chine pour
marquer la pose de lecture je chipote
peut-être mais les correcteurs se
plaignent des négligences de ponctuation
dans les rapports du jury la phrase est
bien liée à la précédente par l'adverbe
également qui a toutefois déjà été
utilisée à deux ou trois reprises
donc c'est un lien logique d'addition
alors sur la forme il n'y a rien à dire
parce que la phrase est courte et très
clair d'ailleurs varier les phrases
longues et les phrases courtes
c'est une bonne manière de dynamiser un
texte sur le fond en revanche ça ne va
pas parce que l'enjeu du paragraphe c de
métrer que l'opposition des stratégies
militaires est le reflet d'une
opposition intellectuel et culturel
or là l'élève fait le parallèle il dit
grosso modo c'est pareil en chine
il fallait plutôt écrire quelque chose
comme en chine
le débat est conçu comme une forme
différente d'affrontements je passe à la
phrase suivante
là encore la stratégie chinoise y est
celle de l'affrontement indirecte cette
phrase précise la précédente puisqu'elle
evel de quelle forme d'affrontement il
s'agit l'allocution là encore est juste
mais on ne perçoit pas assez facilement
que le lien d'addition concerne l'idée
de l'affrontement indirects dans la
stratégie militaire chinoise l'idée qui
est exprimée dans les paragraphes
précédents et qu'elle ne concerne pas en
fait la phrase précédente
donc en réalité cette phrase s'oppose à
la précédente qui rapproche elle les
conceptions du débat en occident et en
chine en gardant la phrase précédente il
fallait plutôt écrire dans le détail
cependant cette conception présente la
même préférence pour le billet que la
stratégie militaire chinoise
mais bon sur la forme c'est quand même
très clair ce qui s'explique en bonne
partie par le fait que la phrase est
plutôt courte
il ya juste la répétition du terme
affrontements mais ça n'est pas très
grave
je continue
en exprimant jamais
on monte une idée le débatteur chinois
n'en a aucune
à défendre et peut aisément manipuler
son adversaire comme avec la stratégie
militaire
quand elles n'existent qu'en puissance
alors cette phrase développe ce qu'est
l'affrontement indirects dans la
tradition chinoise du débat donc elle
est cohérente
c'est très clair et très efficace
jusqu'à manipuler son adversaire petit
détail
j'aurais ajouté l'adverbe ainsi après
peu pour bien signalé la conséquence
sinon ma réticence c'est que la
comparaison avec la stratégie militaire
aurait pu être exprimé plus clairement
j'aurais par exemple écrit de la même
manière que la stratégie militaire
courront les anticipations de
l'adversaire mais sinon c'est
globalement clair je passe à la dernière
phrase de la contraction
les conceptions logique sont donc
déterminantes culturellement alors c'est
un peu la conclusion partielle de tout
le paragraphe
elle en reprend d'ailleurs à l'idée de
la première phrase qui était comme
l'introduction partielle du coup sur le
fond cette phrase n'apporte rien est de
ce point de vue là elle est critiquable
pas besoin de faire un résumé dans la
résumer la conjonction donc fait
artificielle parce que la phrase n'est
pas une conséquence de la précédente
toujours sur le fond l'idée n'est pas
très compréhensible qu'est ce que ça
veut dire déterminante culturellement et
puis ils répètent l'expression
conception logique qui ne m'avait déjà
pas convaincu dans la première phrase je
pense qu'il veut dire que les paradigmes
intellectuelle qui sous-tendent les
stratégies militaires comme les
stratégies du discours son propre os
civilisation la civilisation occidentale
et la civilisation chinoise
mais bon
ça n'est pas aux correcteurs de le
deviner au total cette dernière phrase
est plutôt raté elle ne sert pas à grand
chose alors conclusion pour cette ultime
paragraphe on retrouve encore les
grandes qualités des deux premiers
paragraphes à savoir la clarté la
cohérence et la fluidité mais on
retrouve aussi les travers du paragraphe
précédent
le non respect de la consigne d'un
personnalité des imprécisions sur le
fond et puis des fragments de phrase qui
aurait pu être plus clair enfin ce
paragraphe ne commence et ne finit pas
très bien
l'idée n'est pas clair dans la première
phrase et la dernière est une sorte de
conclusion inutile ça c'est pas super
bon je lui ai trouvé pas mal de défauts
à cette contraction
donc je la nôtre est combien alors
faisons un petit bilan des forces et des
faiblesses de la copie
les forces sont assez évidentes les
idées essentielles du texte source sont
présentes et le plan de la contraction
reprend grosso modo le résumé que j'ai
proposé dans l'introduction
c'est très cohérent c'est à dire que les
phrases et les idées sont toutes
connectées qu elles s'enchaînent bien et
que la contraction constitue un tout
efficacement articulé enfin c'est très
clair parce qu'on comprend presque
toujours immédiatement le propos puis je
peux ajouter que je n'ai pas trouvé de
fautes d'orthographe
en lisant pourtant la copie dans le
détail les faiblesses maintenant le
candidat s'est affranchi de deux
consignes de base l'impersonnalité et
l'absence de référence il y à quelques
imprécisions sur le fond certains
fragments de phrase pourrait être plus
clair et il y à quelques répétitions bon
au total je ne vais pas faire la fine
bouche c'est bien sûr une très bonne
copie mais est ce qu elle mérite
vraiment 20 pour ma part je n'ai pas eu
en la lisant la sensation ce petit truc
en plus qui émane de l'excellence j'ai
lu des copines et20 que j'ai trouvé
meilleur et d'autres noté 17 18
du même niveau donc cette copie je la
nôtre est plutôt 17 18
je trouve que les deux phrases à la
forme personnelle ça empêche de mettre
19 20 parce que le principe de
l'exercice quand même c'est de produire
un résumé aussi détaché que possible
pourquoi est-ce que le correcteur a tiré
la note à vin lui parce qu'il a estimé
que les grandes qualités de forme clarté
cohérence fluidité compense très
largement les défauts de la copie et
puis j'imagine que c'est aussi dû à les
circonstances peut-être ou probablement
que les copies avant et après celle ci
dans le tas était vraiment médiocre avec
plein de fautes d'expression et
d'orthographe et c est donc ça crée un
effet de contraste qui booste la note de
cette copie mais bon tant mieux pour le
candidat sa copine ne fait donc pas un
modèle parce qu'elle est loin d'être
parfaite mais on y retrouve tout de même
les ingrédients fondamentaux pour
atteindre l'excellence dans l'exercice
alors comment avoir 20 ans contraction
il faut respecter toutes les consignes
sélectionnés rigoureusement les idées
essentielles dans le texte source
les écrire de manière très claire et
très cohérente
ça y est vous l'avez la formule magique
vous pouvez me poser toutes vos
questions en commentaire et je m'engage
à répondre à chacune d'entre elles pour
rappel le sujet de l'épreuve la copie et
même mes notes de commentaires sont
disponibles en cliquant sur le lien dans
la description
j'espère que ce commentaire de copies va
vous aider à progresser en contraction
sans vous prendre la tête sur ce je vous
souhaite bon courage pour le travail
[Musique]